une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast en balance avec nos
invités date seach ph quand tu es avec
moi dôme planque
si vous avez un projet de pas de casque
ou un podcast que vous avez déjà vous
vous la main au niveau on loue le studio
sf6 ou est ce qu'on en a juste le
sans-fil podcast ça vient avec tout
l'équipement ça vient avec la ou le
technicien parce que oui nicole n'est
plus seul on a aussi catherine qui
travaillent avec nous maintenant vous
avez juste besoin de rentrer ici
pensez à votre contenu et vous avez un
service clé en main pour faire le
podcast que vous avez toujours rêvé de
faire sinon d'hommes cette semaine qui
on a reçu cette semaine on a reçu
l'humoriste pierre yves roy desmarais
qui me fait incroyablement rire c'est
une super belle discussion
juste avant qu'on en parle un petit peu
plus on va les remercie nos familles
précieux commanditaires sans qui on ne
pourrait faire ce podcast le bas car
aujourd'hui est présenté par world of
our si de la nourriture pour chiens à la
fine pointe de la technologie des
produits innovants des produits
hypoallergéniques des protéines
alternatives s'est fait ici par une
jeune équipe passionnée au québec et par
mois pendant plus périlleux pardon offre
des gâteries à base de grilles on y
offre des gâteries à base d'algues de la
gaspésie et de pulpe de jure recyclé se
sucrer les pubs des jus qui sont faits
pierrre utilise pour faire des gâteries
pour les chiens il ya aussi de la
nourriture pour chiens à base d'insectes
et la nourriture pour chiens à base de
poisson durable la dernière fois j'avais
parlé des poissons de grammont à
quelques questions à ce sujet là fait
que je vous reviens là dessus c'est la
carte patriotique en fait qui détruit
les fonds marins et les écosystèmes
elle doit pas être pêchés et walter et
le travail avec des pêcheurs nord
américains qui s'occupent de garde un
écosystème 5 dans les mers
on a un code promo bat code provost un
code promo dis-je pour vous pour 20 %
sur toutes les commandes de la boutique
en ligne
c'est le
studio sfr 20 fait qu'utiliser le 4e
mondiaux sf 20 sur leur site web
mon chien sauve le monde point c'est à
tous en un mot votre chien va adorer qui
d'hommes roulé de doxa au cou
merci war 2 où il ya le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté par l'artiste
abitibien gabriel côté qui présente son
nouvel album libère osys libéraux this
qui est un album prog un album concept
inspiré du rock progressif puis du jazz
gabriel fait 100% de l'album donc que ce
soit de la production du de
l'interprétation des instruments des
vocaux que ce soit le mix
tout cela a été fait par gabriel côté
puis on a eu la chance d'écouter l'album
d'hommes qu'est-ce qu'on a passé ouais
moi j'écoutais seul album de gabrielle
côté le dire tout de suite si vous aimez
des artistes comme justin bieber ariana
grain deschamps demande à ce que vous
traitiez pas sur la côte est grave
si vous tapez sur des trucs un peu plus
expérimental sur sa mort ça me fait
penser à du vieux pink floyd le début de
pink floyd
cast est vraiment psychédélique fait pas
sens ccc du rock c'est ce pape lanners
et s'est noyé dans dans louis veut c'est
vraiment des ambiances qui est du saxo
travers d'être ce puits
c'est ce qu'ils gagnent justement qui a
joué tous les instruments la touche
quand même c'est impressionnant ses
senneurs un peu c'est pastore c'est vrai
cette posture et post-rock sais pas ce
qui m'a fait penser aussi au groupe
montréalais godspeed you black
perry mentale serment à kofax et vous
trippé sur des trucs un petit peu plus
éclatée marginal et ji avait choqué
c'est libéraux 6 2 gabriel côté moi j'ai
eu un iphone écouter ce décret à
l'artiste puis allez découvrir sa vie
même si vous tes enfants du tp sur
justin bieber a rien à regretter
peut-être que vous allez encore plus
tripes et son frère découvrir une
nouvelle panoplie de musiques nouvelles
musiques à préserver sa nippo qui
pouvaient exister mais qui sera crime ça
me parle de rock psychédélique
évidemment la bonne soirée sur toutes
les plateformes de streaming mais aussi
sur youtube c'est le lien de youtube
qu'on va mettre dans la description du
podcast bonne écoute puis bonne chance
avec ton projet gamme et garde donc très
comique comique temps comique comique
qui stand commun qu'un mec stéphanois ne
s'écoulent les conversations plus
légères un petit peu comme seul roman
drôle liste est un brillant drôle c'est
vrai que c'est le fun parce que yi fang
et justice
les fans russes positif c'est juste
c'est juste ce cessez le feu quelqu'un
qui a trouvé un petit peu qu'il ait pas
dans son oeuvre dans son humour qui est
à l'aise avec ce titre qu'il a subi moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ce puis on
a aussi on aussi raconter certaines
strauss que d'hommes s'est chié dessus
en fait bouger trop d'histoires j'ai
trop d'histoires de situation merdique
vraiment littéralement merdique
également plus que jamais compter
d'aujourd'hui que vous allez voir ce
dont le sinon ben on ne parlait dans le
parler des dérives ne te parler de lui
de sa carrière de ses études à l'école
de l'humour c'est d'amuser coup-ci que
fait on a parlé de deux sujets qui me
passionnent aussi l'espèce de d'amour
haine qu on a prolongé une discussion
sociaux et une présence constante on
pourrait dire une constants merci pierre
yves devenus ces techniques puis merci à
vous d'être abonné vous a toutes nos
chances
si lointaine de 180 partout vous le
pouvez top up cliquez sur live qui
souhaitent sur you double cliquer sur
like an serment qui dessine dans les
commentaires qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la compensation sans plus attendre
bonne écoute non pas quatre
[Musique]
ça vole c'est pas si chacun bienvenue
sur notre podcast
d'après notre quotidienne de fiction ou
est ce qu'on continue l'histoire de la
semaine passée c'était fou se sait c'est
les comics orson welles citizen kane
d'orson welles mais lui avait caressé
genre un espèce de fiction à radio radio
1 piste et c'était des évasions des
critères s'appelait puis le monde le
monde
écoutez ceux qui pensaient vraiment
mettons tout changer de poste pluies
tombées ces genres les extraterrestres
nous attaquent ils montrent aujourd'hui
le mari la montagne guylaine tremblay
reçoit des messages de monde qui sont
comme l'orge pas à ma sortie de prison
le monde qu'on respire le foot dans la
rue sans qu'un petit pas fait leurs
classes bilingues choix qui ne tiendront
à tout un livre que le puits est la
fille la plus drôle pourrait plus genre
d'ici là je vous le gardien de prison
qui a choisi insulté nager vite et c'est
sûr que dans la fiction c'est toute
l'information possible attaque et les
lendemains qui jouait avec la fiction le
tic sont gardés je vais que la fiction
de la réalité prendre un média vraiment
rationnelles phare jour un bulletin de
nouvelles le tue comme son noble c'est
un bulletin de nouvelles
mais complètement fonctionnel sans
vraiment la dre city way majan ce bain
crime et il y en a qui le font chaque
simbaya oui mais si j'avais
directionnelle fois plus de maillots que
les armées
un web et j'ai l'impression c'est aussi
une tendance l'adhérence est le plus
réaliste possible de plus en plus utile
l'espèce de caméras est visible et et la
mode apple a dit office la caméra qui
est l'homme qui pullulent ouais c'est ce
que j'aime a commenté win connaît le
talent fait faux documentaire food and
d'angleterre si l'on sait bien il est
honnête il acheter l'album de six
panneaux tap
c'est original oui c'est des tonnes de
bonne tonne rock qui est sinon il me
reste andy kaufman shaw cyclisme
intéressante et des choqué il tirait
montrant fabrique d'andouilles ainsi
tout son truc est ce que je poserai ou
est-ce que je posais paris qu'est ce qui
est vrai qu est-ce qui peut vrai sur ce
malade puis j'aime aussi quand tu viens
au point la question des roms puis
j'aime j'aime aussi cac c'est l'humour
et comme transporté dans d'autres
dimensions que si on peut juste comme
lost un spectacle le ticket l'oeil et
jean atv je sais pas dans paris publié
comme quelqu'un d'autre mais j'aime tout
c'est afin d'amener ça ailleurs le site
de sortir il ya un gars qui fait au
québec c'est sûr que tu connais le
montreuil anthony montrer oui les
semaines je suis pilote et les basco
j'en ressors mon projet de musique
j'suis vrai ou pas vrai je l'aï vraiment
une xsara
mais ces sixièmes à une bonne idée le
tissu c'est drôle de fin imaginez ça
sera plus sage ou à radio
le ca roule plus il va faire des
entrevues puis tout ceux qui le
reçoivent 100 comment la nouvelle étoile
montant de la musique et tout de suite
sont au courant se trouve ça magique le
type ils veulent nourrir ce chaque
touche est malade justement parce que
c'est pas assez fait comme la toune
jeudi à ce passeport leur gamme ans et
pourtant si c'est pas évident que c'est
une joke est si tu peux l'aimer c'est
pas trop tôt c'est comme ça aligne déjà
voyons je trouve que le panier mais
j'adore j'adore ça car ceux-ci 4 fait
partie de la taxe locale
quant au milieu un chiffre jamais ça
mais c'était pour rire de moi fil blanc
qui avait sorti une loi de fourre-tout
nous sommes en effet il y avait des gens
à utiliser ton album pleut dans sa vidéo
teaser ton album tu es des genres leader
freire puis paul daraîche le pied plein
de monde qui avaient embarqué dans jo
qui n'était pas dans la sueur de l'album
qui dépose sur l'album puis avec irene
avant c'était vraiment une pop plus tard
les deux frappent le tout le monde
c'était comme s'ils faisaient le break
est en train de virer fois king pop
bayonnaise
puis il prend du monde considéré comme
28 m'appliquer tandis qu'ils amènent
dans sa job dans son vidéo lettres puis
à ce que nintendo mais comment savoir
comment tu vois ça va très mal
ouais c'est des montagnes russes magna
on n'allait pas bien
ben on a fait des podcasts avec un gars
qui va pas bien pas bien on a absorbé ce
pilot ont fait tout le temps un jour de
20 minutes une demi heure après le
podcast parce que onze ans pour le
mettre nos pitchouns halfway steve maine
c'est la chose la plus déprimante au
qu'ils aient honte et leur métier alain
g et a links pareil plus on sait le da
mata en fait propice en ligne c'est
juste deux jeunes c'est ça va mal je
suis déprimé piège à pigeon chienlit là
on aurait dit la radio pirate des défis
pour n être qu a pu retirer les
documents on mettra pas les fait pas et
c'est qu'ils n'ont plus j'imagine oui
mais pas castelroussine
ouais c pip et elle il ya une passe trop
flou on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya comme et
fait l'erreur de voyage que des
conseillers mais avant mettons que
c'était des conseillers mais à part les
mêmes droits ce métis t'es pas des baux
société met toi bien c'en est devenu un
point qui lui volera sont devenu le bouc
émissaire dnca de tous les problèmes de
la société
lui s'est fait pointer du doigt puis je
voudrais évidemment ça y est rentré dans
l'implicite encore un peu genre chez
potosi joue encore faire ça dans la vie
puis georges retournent aux études mais
j'aime pas vraiment ce qu'il est et
comme pau virtual boy est vraiment laid
ni vraiment pessimiste le surge son
propre avenir sur l'avenir général
pigeât surtout qui surtout que sur
l'avenir des réseaux sociaux ce qui est
qu'il nous est ce que lui
essayez fait sa carrière sur les réseaux
sociaux puisque l'association devient
aussi tendue mais calme pippa juste lui
le taiseux dire en général tout cas que
tu t'investis dans quelque chose au
complet le piqué ça fait des années que
tu fais sopic le soudainement faut que
t'arrêtes mais c'est pas ton choix ce
qui est grave la ferme en plus les gueux
ne voulait pas qu'on traverse et le tout
ce qu'ils voulaient faire mais se
divertir le monde faire des sketchs même
faire des trucs drôles le couper de la
glu qu'un coupon un couteau cholet je
pense que c'est une question vraiment
ces puits ont lancé hier sa mère exemple
c'est comme dans une situation aussi
sauf que là la pandémie actuelle touche
on reviendra sur comment tout tu vis
seul est temps d'arrêter de parler j'ai
le feeling que c'est vraiment une
question d comme d'essayer de trouver le
plus de positif
plus de place possible les gens avec qui
tu parles de quoi parce que sinon c'est
super avec des chars le coma suis
surtout là la pandémie depuis ou est ce
qu on en est rendu maintenant ben écoute
c'est ça dépend de ce qui se passe des
dommages collatéraux laitiers une pause
plus dur
le savon c'est quand même ce que je
trouve dommage en ce moment c'est que
mon bonheur des passants pour sade de
demain de ce qui se passe dans ma vie
dit j'aimerais ça être capable de
commencer ce peu importe ce qui se passe
je force morale tellement fragile que le
ça va super bien parce que tout le reste
vaut bien ses stocks il ya des petit
arbuste ou des gens bouchard a quand
même pas mal loin si ça m'aide ayant
l'un des plus grands au sein de cette
fac et dépendamment des moments c'est
drôle c'est ce que je trouve plate ce
qui est idiot d'avoir le moral béton et
le moral est très fragile c'est
dépendant de 2,2 tout ce qui m'entoure
de tirer sa rester créatif puis
productif malgré la pandémie mettant au
début oui au début mais ne te sens pas
les vidéos de tous quelque chose que je
faisais pas avant mais je faisais en
fait c'est juste été un genre de
concentration dessus tout ce que j'ai
toujours fait le stade des jo l'amusé
p-dg de vie des autres ça a été comme
l'apogée de ce pilot trois matches comme
j'essaie de focus et sur mon spectacle
qui va sortir quand qu'on aura le droit
de faire un spectacle mais pour
l'instant j'essaie de focus est là
dessus puisque c'est difficile de se
mettre en mode spectacle en tant fait
pour pente
moi je les ai recommencé le dentiste
peut casser ça sent le truc mais les
chaussures autour de 26 quoi penser
le 26 février un pays qui en fait un
show ouais ça a ouvert la zone orange et
spectacles j'ai fait un show à rivière
du loup en zone orange l'iphone était
malade le touché à un oeil et un bouquet
piéton puis la journée que ça ouvert son
garage et des bielles ils sont présentés
puis moi ce que je fais c'est que je
loue des salles partout c'est en ce
moment puis en espérant que ça soit zone
orange le moment où ils ont été chanceux
avant tout était annulé
ça a donné on avait le 25 à rimouski
[Rires]
mais ouais c 'est fac et leur à ce
moment j'en ai d'autres sociétés mais
qui sont tout en rouge mais c'était
quand même très malade c'était vraiment
le fun tout le monde porter des masques
un jeu c'est la fac m'a fait faire le
plus long saut parce que cet automne
l'uqam est en fait cet été cet automne
il eu des shows la 250 places mac c'est
quand même rangée sur deux qui est vide
il allait déranger que du monde il ya
trois sièges vides entre chaque groupe
de personnes ces souches avec salades
soupes mais les masques j'ai fait quand
même c'est quand même une heure et demie
de show de monde à s'exécuter voit pas
trop sourire ces réactions le désintérêt
quand même si puis l'énergie lorsque le
monde est content de se déplacer aussi
puis moi aussi j'ai dit ce fan parce que
j'arrive pas à me rentrer dans l'attaqué
du monde qui sont prêtes à braver une
pandémie pour aller s'asseoir écouter
les jo classique fac et d'instinct s'est
dit bon moment resté muet d'alphone puis
ça donne le goût de continuer à
renforcer sur la pandémie
ça fait combien de temps que tu as fait
un show devant demain c'était ça faisait
depuis le mois de septembre
ah ouais ouais fac est un genre de
5 - 6 j'ai fait d'autres pages fait
plein show sur internet des corpos zoom
de chez nous dans des studios j'hésitais
de fait la fille et je fais de même un
gala juste pour rire ben ahin personne
n'était dans une salle 100 % à riverside
et livide fin que city j'avais hâte
d'avoir des vraies conditions mais oui
tu étais tu aimes tu est une espèce de
petite fébrilité parce que j'imagine que
quand même et on se fait des choix
chaque soir a amené sa tu tombes un peu
sur le pilote automatique l'émeute avait
tué l'espèce de petite nervosité un
d'horreur du mont houy vraiment pittis
qui est ce que dos et d'en faire des
choix chaque soir je la fais brit air
est jamais c'est parce qu'il ya toujours
du nouveau monde qui tu vas jouer puis
je veux leur offrir le meilleur
spectacle si tu veux pas être comme
porsche un soir c'est la première fois
que ces 130 personnes le mont vue je
pense que ça c'est impressionnant comme
facture est vraiment bon à chaque fois
mais sur internet
au début c'est les premiers chaussures
zoom j'étais vraiment fébrile tu étais
chez vous une horde l'écran de leur ai
fermé plate et frustré c'est dur parce
des jo la ta tête tu veux que ça et bien
plus de ce fait en remettant ses quinze
minutes le stationnement le ou la jab ce
qu'ils me députée ruth à dose
d'adrénaline
puis plus de ça avance plus tout un sac
voit même pas le monde des fois c'est
des plateformes ce que tu te vois toi
même tu entends pas les rites voire du
visage tu sais même pas s'il pourra voir
personne je saurai pas la nervosité puis
l'espèce d'excitation de spectacle et
puis lol t'es juste devant ton ordi je
t'ai comment vais-je temps chaud dans
ces minutes filent comme en ont
peut-être jamais des peines boulot c'est
qu'on me joggi tard l'une des caméras
jo c'est terrible c'est vraiment pas le
fonds dispose pas des choses à fond club
de retrouver la vraie elle d'entendre du
monde le 11 janvier avant le début du
show là tout l'art du tir c'est
l'excitation était le week-end ça tubes
en été ç'a très bien été
ces chaînes j'étais rouillé c'est parce
que c'est un risque qui se travaille et
wii puis les jo kossity les ioniens
rythme après la fatigue qu'il faut que
tu gardes tu gardes actives qu'il ne
serait-ce que juste le matériel comme
tel c'est ça faisait juste jeudi s'ils
échouent virtuel jamais plus qu'une demi
heure parce que c'est insupportable
oui même si vaincu leur accord chaque
1h15 de jo c'est beaucoup de jobs ainsi
de se rappeler le sud des fois si le
rythme étant rappelée par le fait que je
me suis trouvé grouiller mais je dis
fans aux gouttelettes
qu'est ce qui se passe si vraiment
mettons le ca te revient paul l'ado que
c'est une question classique le degré
qui possède et humoriste même moi je me
dis crime une heure et cordes et parker
c'est énorme
ouais vraiment beaucoup est-ce que tu
est une difficulté ce site stuff se
souvenir d'eux non pas des plus à
l'intérieur parce que ces cassettes ou
qu'ils écrivent ces taux qui ira d'après
ses dires fait beaucoup le terme hacker
le ce qui est plus dur des fois c'est
une nouvelle drogue c'était cette année
je sais pas me lance que pour moi ce
pont difficulté de se rappeler des
joggeurs surtout que sur scène jeunes
filles avec leur bébé avec jean des mots
clés c'est vrai que je me rappelle de
tout ce qu'il faut je passais puisqu'un
oublie quelque chose quand tu inverse
des affaires c'est pour les sages et
peut-être le speech son luxe de rodage
match comme génial avec ce choix
cette affaire ce programme relatif à
quai et j'essaie de garder contre un
background un peu ouais effectué six
métaux a amené choses qui se passent pas
très peur le nom si c'est petit si je
tape personnage j'imagine ce serait plus
compliqué lundi 17 pièces de théâtre
joli bond factice et j'agirai cette
rencontre avec le monde tout en douceur
y'a pas un quatrième étant qui est en
train de faire une pièce de shakespeare
plutôt bling bling
le ccqab aux règles ci-dessus bajazet
clément ces candidats pensent que
calandre maintenant dix offices les
camps indie fait sa pièce de théâtre les
minimes où le flat que les dodge a
essayé de rattraper son et promet sa
faune se tend de plus en plus d'art dans
la mare qui viennent forme assez bon
mais toi tu es dogues sont issues sont
sans le cinq et non les billets sont ce
sont ces genres à virgule pour mon prêt
août à une des pistes comme titre a
jusqu'au point libre et de celle du rsa
la plupart des jo que le web est en fait
le wording est vraiment travailler le
cfaa qui je déroge jamais vraiment ce
qui là où je me donne vraiment la marge
de manoeuvre c'est dans les acteurs
qu'on appelle fac c'est souvent quand tu
quand tu joues le joystick acteurs jack
était comme interprété par un personnage
invisible je me suis je dit mettons
jeudi tyler ma mère est abusif attend
maintenant
[Rires]
internet c'est lorsque des fois tu mets
plus de cinquante cinquième jeu les
parts élèves le team et sinon ouais ça
je ne sais pas s'ils n'ont en général
les jo qui est il racheter les petites
phrases à garder ce qu'ils vivent qui
vit oui mais les dogues le wording est
vraiment importante que j'accorde
beaucoup d'importance à sauf à qui ça
sonne pas mal de matchs éliminatoires et
puis même si jésus change toujours la
méthode d'écriture lui même si je ne
mets pas sur papier comme tel je me
souviens le de comment je le dis aime la
musique là qui vient avec toi ce soir
que le délai bruit et qu'il soit
important mais j'ai l'impression que tu
veux c'est ce que je cherche tout le
temps des livres usagés la bagarre a
fait rage et a menacé d'avoir une phrase
m'est donc qui revient tout le temps
enfin la fin de la maintenance de bien
la foire puis déportés de toujours c'est
d'y aller en pointe c'est ce que ces
bébés pour faire passer le goût du jour
mais je pense que lorsque ces belles
techniques là mais je pense que
l'important c'est de comprendre pourquoi
c'est drôle si c'est vraiment parce que
si toutes les petites subtilités qui
font que se déroule pas besoin de
réfléchir c'est très juste à essayer de
remodeler c'était sympa d'affaires
inquiets quand j monsieur vaincu la
chine et qu'il
c'est quand même pourquoi allemand
torsten wolf a qu à penser cela
[Rires]
déchaîné q la jeunesse martin hirsch ex
ryan et moi même si une inculte 5
étoiles attendait le bo de recul
hugo 12 morts sans la france à l'école
denis mollat les bruits luxe ni assez
bon penses tu que tu aurais fait si ce
n'était pas là à l'école de l'humour
assez vraiment de bonnes questions
parce que c'était un rêve le mot de fin
du monde si c'était ça l'objectif
puis c'est dur à dire parce que je sais
pas si j'aurais eu du fun à sauter dans
le monde des bars sans aucune audience
les deux ans l'école de le mot c'est
vraiment ce que pour moi ça a été super
bénéfique parce que tu exploiter puis
j'ai besoin de tâter le terrain et
devrait même sentir complètement
confiance que j'avais besoin le titre de
ce moment le losc était entouré de 15
amis qui ont le même objectif qui ont le
même âge à peu près puis le on développe
une cohésion au fait que les cellules
une jarre la confiance qui s'installe de
le justice a devant vous autres mais je
le ferai pas dans d'autres mondes enfin
que ce moment là j'aurais été vraiment
charnière pour moi super important enfin
que c'est une bonne question genre étude
est capable je sais pas je sais pas je
pense que oui les ultimes louis et parce
que c'était vraiment j'avais un objectif
en tête je le sais que je m'étais dit si
je pas pris je veux faire des shows le
plus possible d'un bolt fait que
sûrement oui mais est-ce que lorsque
c'est ce que je leur ferai pas s'en
faire l'écho le monde si quoi que si
quoi que ça a plus amélioré mes temps
d'antonov à l'école c'est vraiment
développer la confiance puisque c'est de
développer aussi mais l'humain je pense
hangzhou clé si je pensais même pas tant
le niveau technique que le vraiment
développe c'est vraiment important est
d'être c'est parce que c'est un jumeau
c'est tellement proches c'est la
personne qui sur scène est tellement
proche de son personnage au support
important c'est comme ça fait partie de
six pour ça qu'on se fait constamment
dit ouais ça pourrait finalement pas si
facile parce que c'est comme naturel
tout était cave tous été détectés tout
les gens la proximité que les gens se
sentent avec mesure de tout ce qui se
permet de nous parce que ayant
l'impression qu'on est un peu juste en
train de jaser pendant une heure
beaucoup de travail tactique c'est seule
espèce de défi fin qu'il faut aussi que
la personne soit assez mature assez
brillante assez allumés assez empathique
pour parler de toutes sortes d'affaires
sur scène d'être pertinent afin de
développer cette rumeur qui développe
son empathie qui toutes les autres qui
se posent des questions de ce camp
j'agis même si c'était tellement tout le
temps avec le même monde que vient de
poser des questions sur toi-même puis
surtout j'ai remarqué c'est surtout
c'est un passant qui le monde vit le
même genre de crise au début de la
deuxième année de kiffa club bientôt je
veux sortir de l'école saint cloud est
un peu d'argent faux choc a pas de
marché de buddh seuls ces facs et
beaucoup cette semaine à faire beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres suspects y ont passé
ce travail l'homme qui a été vraiment
vraiment importante et je les fait j'ai
fait une université pendant un an et
demi
vingt deux ans à fond les devants 2 1 je
suis rentrée à l'école de l'humour
j'aurais pu t adèle cégep à l'école le
mot je me jetais pollock personnellement
dans la vie avec ils l'ont fait dans la
cohorte et y en a qui ont indiqué qu'ils
sont rentrés pluvieux puis je l'aurais
pas fait différemment je n'aurais pas
été plus jeunes c'est plus jeune
j'aurais pas été assez mature pour
vraiment lever puis comme est vraiment
un bon humoriste mais j'avais besoin de
mûrir un peu plus tôt c'est vraiment
intéressant mais je mettais pas c'est
une réflexion quant à moi j'ai fait mon
parcours en littérature à l'université
puis puis un brin la natation fixé entre
l'école puis le support maintenant je
n'avais pas beaucoup de temps de deux
véhicules étaient de faire autre chose
c'est ce qui est arrivé à fin de mon
parcours j'ai comme la mesure à me dire
à quel âge et des outils mais sur coup
j'écris parce que parce que j'ai pas
vécu à porter
le fond d'une piscine puis le parcours
se fait qu'est ce que je fais maintenant
chantaient que j'avais besoin mettons de
vivre quelque chose avant de pouvoir le
transposer en norme temps ouais je
trouve ça intéressant de dire peut-être
se concentrer sur le la de faire grandir
l'humain avant d'essayer de avant
d'avoir quelque chose à dire maintenant
c'est même pas juste en d'avoir vécu des
affaires mais je trouve c'est plus de
lait c'est vraiment aussi dans l'ailé
l'obs et ne serait-ce que d'observer
autre chose que ta petit kart et jeunes
aux activités beaucoup de je sais pas et
qu'il te plaît l'empathie à ce que moi
personnellement c'est ça des peuples
chaque personne avec moi personnellement
j'avais pas l'empathie si nécessaire
pour vraiment voir les yeux assez ouvert
pour comprendre que si ce qui fait
réellement c'est ce qu'ils trouveront là
dedans c'est une donne ton sens de
l'humour vieillit aussi 10 pour ceux ci
peut pas avoir un petit pas vraiment un
excellent musicien 12 ans virtuose
je dis oui va être drôle pour un petit
gars de 12 ans c'est vrai qu'on voit pas
ses instincts possible qu'ils soient
plus parce que et ça prend une
compréhension du monde sont capables de
lire
reid d'euros ne comprend pas qui c'est
quoi la barre ce moment qu'est ce que
c'est quand tu es jeune lentilles comme
je sais que je voulais tu m'enrichis
jésuite frères et mes parents puis
s'était jamais ce que je pensais que les
foires et qui faisait rire au final les
seuils de portes chic emmène a dit mme
et essaie juste de recréer les patins
que tu veux mais tu es comprend poser
c'est quand même juste toi même pigou
fait à la salle et fait rêver mais je
comprends pas facteur pas le recul sur
ta propre personnage qui sait ce que
j'ai l'air dans ce groupe de jean lob
c'est ce qui fait rêver les gens en
général c'est parce que le monde entier
ça prend c'est dur à expliquer mais foot
absorbe beaucoup de comment le monde
fonctionne puis c'est plus long pour
certains mots ça a été juste un petit
peu plus long il y en a qui ont une
maturité
plus arty où j'étais je pense pas que
c'est immature mais je pense j'avais
besoin de deux murs est ressorti de
faire mûrir cette affaire le tpiy c'est
l'autre ça c'est l'autre affaire qui
après si tu réalises mais mais mais
peut-être que c'est dans l'oeil de
houdan mon oeil à moitié tandis que
c'est trop dans mon quotidien six mois
tu ya pas grand chose à faire avec ce
juste pas si ça fait du sens l'ipo alors
je sais quand tu le vis tous les jours
des mdr c'est comme tu dis ok puis mais
on ne tient maintenant pascal ton froid
il fait un film s'appelle nadia
butterfly qui était chose à cannes en
fermant puis c'est pascal dans le fond
il y avait un peu ce que je raconte le
dr chris noth tout ce que j'ai fait dans
ma vie c'est du sport puis l'école de
cinéma mais ce qui est fait c'est un
film sur la natation puis qui a été
super bien reçu
parce qu'en bout de ligne si c'est pour
toi pour toi c'est normal les bananes
les gens disent pas de haut niveau si
ces points pour cent la population qui
fuit 6-3 du support intéressant et crie
pitié je pense que thil et on a beaucoup
d'affaires en dedans de nous aussi puis
le monde autour de nous est assez riche
pour être capable de parler de soldats
fargo tôt si je pense qu'on n'est pas
obligé d'aller dans les faire un safari
ou dispense proche de mourir pour avoir
une anecdote à compter sur cinq défis
que pose la question c'est en tant qu
m'en restait que deux mares raconté m
c'est l'amorcé d'une limousine est bien
cursive on te souviens d'un singe
d'école j'y passe à des anecdotes de
même mais c'est pas grave
j'essaie la fois je me suis le chili
c'est ça mon message pour les jeunes
sous les couleurs d'une fois au bluff
mais c'est l'histoire que je me suis dit
que j'allais plusieurs années j'ai
maintenant j'ai pas d'anecdotes dans vie
puis je rêve d'une anecdote ou je me
serais chier necula c'est ces gens
disent et de l'orge fait un petit peu de
course à pied
c'est sa maison mais n'importe qui qui
s'entraîne maintenant les longues
sorties le temps d'une de ces jeunes
exploitants qui me tombe cherchent
activement la journée une des courses je
te plaît elle est une des courses je
suis inquiet c'est une histoire de
shilin culotte de coder histoire de
finale culotte de voyage et j'ai hâte
d'être c'est pas toi de revenus des
titres choisis on va rechausser leurs
dollars mais non oui où il a droit
le nom qui première histoire elle que je
m'en allais compte et ça serait
petite course en amoureux ok j'arrête
l'histoire est complètement gelé en
république dominicaine
ok parfait j'aurais levé de soleil sur
les 60 san francisco oui oui je survie
en forêt rimouski si jamais compter
celles là j'ai déjà parlé mais souvent
mais c'est le jir penser hier puis je me
suis dit j'ai jamais content et ça à
personne dans mon enfance activement je
n'ai jamais dit j'ai jamais s'est jamais
sorti de ma bouche et histoire mais à
chaque été casté jeune j'allais une
semaine chez mon programme à montréal
à rimouski faire un qu'un avec mon
cousin on a une semaine on fait un camp
d'équitation de fêter un gain de 2 ci
dessus pour autant quand survie puis la
dernière journée on allait sur une île
mme way lillers muskin on est les lots
si on venait de théodore mais lolo des
renforts et picoty puis la deuxième
journée on ne confère à la marche le
tour des lycées pin en mauges avait à
voir je sais pas 10 puis ça vraiment
gêné je te rends très gênés puis josep
au dire des choses comme j'ai envie que
quand même plus
mais même en laissant alors a pas de
punch lui je le disais on s'est échinée
qu'il attaquait mais finalement j'ai
juste comme passer tout l'est
alors comment cela marche ils en ont
envie j'ai envie j'ai envie mais là il
n'y a pas de toilettes le pilote avec
les moniteurs les autres petit enfant
puis je n'osais pas regarder donc josé
pas disait que j'avais envie je marchais
seule catégorie à serrer les fesses ni
même le saas mais ça se marie
les journées d'un culte qui le safer
catchy ce qu'ils ont juste continuer je
n'ai rien dit de soja à la moitié de la
marche avec n'y resterai même tout les
reste la marche des lille que le move
marché banbury bleus tout le monde
hommes de montella avait diffamé jallet
aucun phone bateau sur l'île en radiant
way techno revient à dire qu'avec le
voilà au 10 mars
[Musique]
si bon écoutez moi ça ne m'a pas rappelé
le soleil faisait rien dit rien et puis
le finalement on arrive
genre tu sais mon père est mort entre
jeu on est juste rentré dans le cadre de
portes
puis mon mon parrain fait allez vous
avez eu une grosse journée pourriez
prendre votre douche suite aujourd'hui
comment lui ça on négocie avec pas mal
ces présidents qui a besoin d'une 2e
j'ai passé j'avais déshabille je me suis
dit dans un cas que le titre sur 10 ans
[Rires]
j'ai trop généreux mais moi j'aime bien
je vais faire c'est plus rapide le mais
j'aime l'histoire course en amoureux je
voulais vous dire qui est le short est
une fille s'appelle stéphanie françois
fillon à l'école a pas de casse on la
salue on a salué bien avoir un bébé
félicitations à vous pis le hâle rem et
suso d'ailleurs telle heure on veut
courir à québec on vous connaît centile
autour d'universités laval une santé
dans le bourg de télé pour parcourir la
clé on va là puis pourrait à koursk ans
satcon mathis comme si le mouvement ça
fait descendre soit arrête
automatiquement tu marches ou chouachi
annoncé sans rien enfin fait la malle de
j'essaie de le trophée je te fais encore
une fois tu sais qui le met hors jeu
quand je fais un pas de plus ça me chie
dessus puis j'ai déjà vécu ce qui s'est
passé
je suis pas surveillée puis fait le kilo
je le trouve un plan trouve un plein tac
le jeudi et arrête tout on arrête tout
en fait un jeu qui croyant qui quoi
c'est ont fait un tour à midi avec le
film avec adam sandler le drôle
d'appareil
je suis gay béchard qui en fait un jeu
où je courais un peu plus et de caltech
c'est en fait un tour je te donne à 30
secondes avant ce port vite et on voit
si avant la fin du tout
on voit ça avant la fin du tour je peux
être apprise c'est que l'on voit que
karim a promis la caf et petits tacles à
un but trop gola pourquoi pas à courir
parce qu'ils le valent albeau suspendu 3
fin je me suis je pour accoster
je les rattrape et 30 à 35 ans c'est
peut être bien mais pas si je serais pas
allé
rentrait pas trop bande à ballack
d'accès les autres pour un autre dicton
pas d'anecdotes en général ou te tombent
un geste j'en ai pas humoriste
d'anecdotes non non vraiment pas
j'aimerais ça je me suis dit 'je
arracher le gain qu'ils lancent dans des
situations le podium ouais ouais j'en ai
peut-être si comme cage sans danger
souvent je m'éloigne et moi c'est pas
mon style mettons du mot préféré
vraiment le tlm risquent vraiment ce
qu'ils font mais quelque chose qui
m'impressionne temps dgac et michel
barrette de pouvoir faire des shows
après chaud après show d'anecdotes jeudi
jour de 3 à 2 j'écoutais ces écoutes
puis jimmy jam et enfin son ton picture
taken by mettons à noël vous raconter
ses anecdotes illégaux ces malades mais
j'en ai passé j'en ai souvent souvent
c'est plus des affaires que je me rabats
oui c'est vrai j'ai vécu ça puis le sait
le trouve une touriste comex et spots a
comme il m'est arrivé à la fin vogel
prenant note strzoda c'est simple tout
seul quand j'ai des boues d'anecdotes
plus des histoires que j'ai trouvé une
manière de trouver un angle pour la tva
à définir le ton style du monde je sais
pas mais ça là dessus parce que
j'imagine qu'ils 4 à l'école de l'humour
tapera les différents styles
non non non non les road less plutôt de
découvrir toi même c'est que le sol est
plus un genre de chemin qui est tu dois
faire toi-même puis on essaie de ne pas
mettre d'étiquette non plus et tout le
monde
un dentiste un spectre moi je pense le
petit monde un brin d'abc tout le monde
une manière de punch et c'est plus moi
je pense que mana d'interpréter était
bien avec vont trouver ce plus
passionnés de moto et ça plus tard à
tâter ça dépend des goûts aussi latine
s'est habitué justement d'écouté anthony
montreux et moi je suis le gars le plus
stricte au monde quand tu écoutes ça
paraît mais ces écoutes je sais je sais
pas fait les bandes du monde qui compte
justement
merci ça me fait rire des fois les
bateaux mais qui compte ce ne sont pas
de casque de type du monde ils vont ils
vraiment les affaires méchante droite
direct qui font vraiment pitié j'ai
l'impression que vu que met-on mike son
style d'humour des fois se mettront sur
sous écoute 6 taquine le tipi sans
voyante il s'envoie des mails quel
public se sent qu'il ya le droit de jah
fakoly soit méchant tout prétexte que ça
irait said raoul ii ya beaucoup de
jeunes humoristes qui est qui dans la
hotte mike puis qui veulent faire du
maïs mais qui comprennent pas c'est quoi
c'est dû mike ward fait franc je serais
entré sur scène qui dit des mots
villegats bien chier le monde sait mais
ce que ça donnait vraiment que c'est
cette épice étalement des fois c'est
trash
blanc on a aussi une coupe des semaines
charles encore de sujet quand même mais
on n'a reçu que deux semaines et mélanie
maynard pied levé à 18 qui a peut-être
l'école met ont créé un genre de moules
tout l'impression sa façon non justement
me soucie du monde qui vont pas décalé
ben ouais ça va seulement voter non pas
du tout et je pense que c'est les
premiers et les premiers qu on apprend
beaucoup là là là on essaie de théoriser
l'humour beaucoup de ce métier on
t'apprend chemin les formules de djoko
mais je pense que c'est quand même les
affaires qui sont importantes à
comprendre que c'est quand même de
défaut parce que des fois c'est drôle
juste avec les mots et je pense qu'il ya
mille niveau qui vit qui vient de rendre
ce drôle après mais c'est de comprendre
pourquoi tu es la face à surprendre et
comprendre pourquoi de la face et de
roll ça t'amène à poser beaucoup de
questions pire et créer d'autres
manières faites au début tout le monde
écrit un peu de la même manière parce
qu'on apprend justement les gens de
formule mais ce ballon se dissout puis
ces gens là le naturel revient au galop
terre qui est non on encourage même à
essayer des trucs été
je sais qu'ils vont dire ça aussi
souvent c'est du monde que leur style
est bien clair à la tête de son homonyme
recycler c'est juste une fois un
personnage comme teach malade si je
revote personnage ben laden mais j'aime
pas ça je pense que le but c'est surtout
d'explorer fac et moi c'est ce que je
trouve paul mais justement c'est
l'espèce d'exploration sont ouverts à
tout le tg a mais j'ai essayé des
concepts des fois tu sais j'aime ça
aussi et numéro concept que je sais des
personnes âgées un concept puis jamais
sont comme moi parce que ça marcherait
pas trop dans un gala juste pour une
place qui mollet j'en sais beaucoup
l'humour à la télé comme tout les guides
télé du mot souvent assez calmes ans
c'est pas bon pour notre public qui est
sauté on essaie de ratisser large parce
qu'il faut que je pense à telle personne
qui habite à tel endroit qui était
l'ange pit et que moi mais c'est tout le
monde doit se rassembler au final
factice ça oui ça vole beaucoup plus
l'école de l'humour qui est un endroit
d'exploration c'est bon c'est vraiment
cool ce que tu me dises pas intéressante
l'idée d'un spectateur type méthode pour
les chaînes traditionnelles biggles et
les médias conventionnels au tad autant
dans la télé j'imagine que je connais
beaucoup moins que met-on l'industrie du
livre
est ce que vous êtes quelqu'un qu'on
écrivait notre livre de recettes le
dessus tout c'était vraiment ok on est
onze voix si la personne y avait une
personne qui sait s'il y en avait un nom
plus je vais pas mais elle avait un nom
elle avait un enjeu la veine démographie
piste à cette personne là qu'on écrive
exactement comme moi mais qui mettons
que maintenant que moi c'est plus donc
c'est pas sept personnages ou écrire
c'est comme dans l'eau mais lorsqu'on
fait l'heureuse qui du mass market qui
pour la plus grande population
j'imagine que c'est quelque chose qui a
été prouvé que ça fonctionne pour la
population mais sa formatrice mans les
enfants exact mais c'est ce qui est
comme dommage mais c'est comme
obligatoire aussi au final parce que tu
te rends compte que au québec pour
survire il faut toucher à une grosse
faute touche pas fait pour survivre en
général quand tu es dans un médium qui
est des médias au dessus faut que tu
touches à beaucoup de montées puis au
québec on est tellement pottoks c'est 1
8 million que ceux ci mettront ce dealer
pour sauver photo sha cinq cent mille
personnes
mais ces 5000 personnes selon l'an
dernier on s'est beaucoup aussi
cinq semaines personne ne sait rien et
est le pourcentage est minime cefac
study ses 16 ans amel à peu près pour
les revenus publicitaires à blanc aux
etats unis c'est super facile tu peux
avoir quelque chose de super niche est
observée au québec pour ce soit super
populaire pour sa part acheté sa pole
choix de battre contre fax et c'est sûr
que les médias comme les médias
traditionnels comme la télé la radio et
j'imagine même métier les maisons
d'édition éditions ils n'ont pas le
choix de se retrouver ses moyens depuis
on en parle souvent avec avec pièces etc
aussi pour pour cette année qu'on est
tellement à la merci des annonceurs des
revenus publicitaires tu peux pas
prendre un gros risque quand canton
seuls revenus c'est ceux de ses matons
je comprends pourquoi il ya aucune
chaîne de radio de grande écoute qui a
voulu de sous écoute m'étonne je sais
bien trop dangereux
ces cavaliers les affaires qui vont se
dire là dessus qui est que les
annonceurs montfort jason n'est pas
intéressé par ce nom c'est du temps des
personnes qui n'ont cessé le concept de
match patrick mc voudrait se retrouvent
1h06 un peu là la réponse aux médias
traditionnels sur un genre de formules m
cela existe pas dans le mass market
chabaneau exact parce que si je sais un
plus intenses et les revenus de ces des
médias traditionnels c'est les
publicités puis les publicités plutôt de
monde qui coûte aux missions plus tous
les vents cheikh faye si tu veux
survivre clément là c'est cher en foot
ailleurs c'est le monde qui t'écoutent
fac il faut que ce soit très grand
public c'est juste logique c'est ronald
fac c'est juste que je trouve qu'il ya
caisse matros et d'humour à la télé
c'est surtout seuls blancs font les gens
de maulde trouve le cercueil tellement
d'humour à télé que tout le monde se bat
pour la grosse le gros morceau téva que
celle qui met à faire comme en mai le
faut que ce soit super grand public dans
la partie ok je trouve que ça ça ce prêt
de mal
moore qui se pose est un genre de
liberté puis de l'univers humoristique
sur la scène au québec est vraiment plus
vaste que le portrait qu'il m'était des
fois c'est comme si on sous estime peut
résoudre ce top et on parle sont pas
capables de prendre un peu de folie ou
un peu des quelque chose d'original
seppi c'est moi je le remarque
je remarque plus en musique mais des
fois j'ai l'impression que quelqu'un au
nom de vouloir pony c'est à montauban au
nom de vouloir faire de quoi dire en
public
c'est du coup tellement génériques de
marque sont riches en la personne de la
chante super bien ici je la tourne et
bien construite mais genre notamment
rien d'original là qui est finalement ça
n'intéresse personne c'est déjà été
entendu tellement de force et la guerre
ça existe aussi mais c'est sûr et puis
oui effectivement c'est le combat séduit
aussi les débuts à grand public mais se
bat dénaturer ce qui a changé avec avec
les faits qui les lie gens maintenant
peuvent c'est tout est un bon exemple
avoir sa propre plateforme de médias
sociaux puis de faire connaître à
travers ce prix et éventuellement
attirer du monde vert thé chaud parce
que j'imagine l'objectif global si
l'objectif tous ses potes devenir un
influenceur de youtube le ou de facebook
c'est vraiment de faire connaître pour
cap sur le monde se déplace mais ça
c'est quand même ultra intéressant pour
des humoristes un petit peu plus à berne
- la scadd le jeu demande de se faire
connaître parce que avant tu peux pas
lutter non pas que ce soit vraiment bien
vite ici et suscite un autre danger
c'est de l'internet c'est que tu dois
aussi contre les vidéos short de bain
côté des recettes avec des musiques
dynamiques factice et ça aussi c'est un
autre danger c'est de vouloir justement
la vidéo virale le débat
considérant que ce soit super plateau
finances faculté c'est de trouver ta
couleur de trouver ta proposition puis
deux puis c'est pas sorcier le au final
il faut juste soin
faut juste que tu sois toi même et je
pense pas pour moi c'est pour finalité
d'avoir une grosse communauté sur le web
c'est vraiment je m'en cache pas c'est
exact je me suis senti que les gens me
découvrent qu'ils ont envie de l'aimer -
chose ces mots si c'est ce qui me fait
le plus plaisir c'est sûr l'objectif
effectivement ce que je trouve le fun
avec justement on entend des marchés qui
est ici c'est maintenant que tu parlais
thé avec l'école de l'humour c'est de
t'apprendre les outils qu'après ce tu
vas apprendre à connaître soi même peut
utiliser qui vont servir dans ta
carrière métier il autre chose on en
parlait avant de commencer une autre
chose que ta fête qui nous unit c'est
que les teasers médias musicaux et
étudie un acteur de pop jazz dans la
hausse et j ai plus que exactement comme
moi j'ai fait pire
puis je m'en parler de cette épaule le
plus motivés ils étaient les meilleurs
la dame était quand même étant petit
c'est la même chose sa musique souvent
que quand j'étais beaucoup moins qu'ils
disaient j'aurai des gens qui triment
dans un style de musique en particulier
georges paul métal ou bains qui tripent
sur quelque chose puisqu'elle a eu
l'impression que l'école voulait
l'échanger ou bâtiment qui arrive avec
une façon de chanter vraiment
particulière pileux et professé de un
peu d'effort c'est pas tant elles sont
comme non parce que c'est ça ma couronne
en harpie moi j'étais mou de la salle st
georges à pratiquer plus fantasy
après seuls les outils qu'il va
t'apprendre outre la musique et écrire
la musique que tu veux mais je me
servais mais tout ce que je trouve le
fun c'est qu'ils avaient ton ses bagages
le qui aurait pu a été finalement deux
années de ta vie que tu as fait de
courbes flamands s'étaient pas surtout
la forte houle et récupérer parce que tu
fais aujourd'hui ce qui fait que ce soit
ses études la musique n'est pas devenu
et jimi hendrix mais mais tu as fait
acquis qu'à moi je peux utiliser ça
aujourd'hui
pour calculer le fait depuis cette
démarque vraiment fait ça ça te
démarques d'autres qui vous ne pourrez
pas le centre bell la musique a toujours
fait partie de ma vie
moi ce que j'aime est est composée t
elle ça fait toujours égale c'est parce
que je sais qu'il ya du monde qui
entendent m'étonne qu'on chante en duo
mais tourne sur internet puisque 100 km
la cour a compétence sur les mêmes taux
encore à peu près un petit big là que je
me fais mais je compose des vérités
aussi l'appui
mais ça a toujours fait partie mais j'ai
toujours fait depuis que je fais de la
musique ça fait partie des dix films
hostel ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
composer puis s'appuient aujourd'hui tu
sais j'ai quand même et je me mords dit
mon petit studio maison là au début de
la pandémie il s'était vraiment juste
mon ordi ben micro puis le make-up mais
comme j'aime j'aime se compose je vais
toujours au faible depuis que je fais de
la musique puis ses connaissances le
chemin de pouvoir gérer studio pour
enregistrer de sujets tout apprécié au
cga petite faction des connaissances que
tueur groupe c mais la composition comme
tel mais c'est ce qui m'intéressait plus
au cégep steve c'est beaucoup pour en
fait tu te permettre de devenir un
musicien complet très factuelle que tu
puisses faire du studio c'est arrivé est
engagé par un élan quels musiciens
arrivent en studio il donne une charge
puis le tu joues si tu fais juste les
rues se joue ce n'était pas facile parce
que ça prend discipline incroyable s'il
faut que tu joues j'ai foutu voit tous
les jours ce que je faisais mais avec
aucune passion par deux fois puis fac
j'ai une écart at il tort j'en joue
plupart tout mais la composition c'est
rester tous les outils que j'ai appris
mais jamais la théorie musicale
j'adorais sur les courts de corps alger
mais c'est tout
tout ce qui entourait ce j'adorerais ça
fait que ces restes et le piano serré si
c'était mon instrument secondaire ces
gens jouent encore beaucoup factice
dossier reste et puis
ouais ça a fini par tout comme ça sans
traiter depuis sa sortie d'un m'en
servais dans le monde j'aime aussi ma
servait quand je te dise pas calculer
mais effectivement que c'est comme c'est
quand même volontaire de poche juste
faire du stand up
j'aime les spectacles sont des
spectacles sorties finances oui mais
j'aime sentir que je quelqu'un qui a
préparé quelque chose de gai rôti
j'adore le stand-up piscine et j'ai
plein de musulmans risquent de mes
idoles qui sont des mineurs ils
préfèrent le médoc sont des systèmes de
peu mais entre ce que pour l'instant ce
pour un objectif que j'ai de faire un
show 100% system dub même si c'est ma
passion première la je te dirai oui
j'adore le stand up s'est empressé
j'aime j'aime aussi qu'il ya des gens
qui me connaissaient juste par le stand
up puis que le froid qu'il fait aussi
des petites zones mais il ya du monde
faudra il faisait des petites tenues
mais c'est vraiment un stand up mais
j'aime les shows qui a tout l'ouest
utilise la scénographie qui utilise la
musique les personnages tout sauf moi
j'aime ce paquet c'est un peu un
objectif aussi james aussi variés le
show c'est quand même qui a été au final
au final c'est comme 10,81 chaude du
moment et on en à
louis josé houde en tête le t on à ces
genres de la cclat mais au final du
spectacle c'est pas obligé d'être du
projet style montant 81 show d'humour là
ça se peut que des fois elle est excitée
piste s était trompé gain qui disait
qu'elle tient dans son choix
jongler aussi que l'humour là dessus
mais comme des mois de prendre des
pauses enquêteurs de faire un petit
tender puisque ce qui se passe mais au
final c'est l'athlète
ah oui vraiment il pilotait yoroba
lepage qui a fait les one man show au
betis faire ce pas du stand up c'est du
théâtre mais c'est quand même sur un
monologue plein joe gatti il ya marc
messier qui va faire ça au site il comme
il ya plein de monde qui font des
infections qui osent pas appelé one man
show parce qu'on a mis des tags vraiment
nécessaire de jean saucet one man show
absurde ça c'est un one man show avec de
la musique de personnages ça c'est une
pièce de théâtre et d'autres choses il
ya beaucoup de pitié je comprends que
dans le traitement ce pas la même chose
doit évidemment parce que l'élu mots il
ya un genre de ya pas de quatrième set
interagit puis le show bougent beaucoup
mais je pense qu'ils aient moins de
mélanger un peu en sûreté fabien
cloutier il faisait aussi le tinal et
plus théâtral quand même sont heureux
qu'ils puissent jouer avec la fanfare si
toutes ces enfants mais moi j'aime sur
le cigem j'aime jouer avec la forme qui
me dit que c'est un one man show métis
passaient pas 100% stand up trouve ça
drôle ça c'est des ballots il ya un
espèce de noyau dur on devrait déjà ça
c'est pas vraiment stand-up ça c'est pas
vraiment et help il ya beaucoup de
solitude la maladie parce que c'est
devenu comme cool le seul de ces pisse
j'adore ça aussi c'est juste c'est juste
un goûter avec son micro
ce serait beaucoup seul un bon spectacle
que le monde se déplace vers l'est
galicie dati très important peu importe
comment ça s'appelle outils quel style
que singh s'était dessus que tu as
toujours été leader drôle
je sais pas je ne sais pas pour vrai bt
je pense que oui et c'était un peu
saumon sur quoi je me rabats tait parce
que je t'ai pas particulièrement chaud
muscler la shoah tels gauche parce que
je suis en revanche que je faisais de la
ranimer
spectacle fac et ouais mais je pense que
wayne genève au genre et les que claude
n'était pas seul le but n'est pas de
punch et en classe tout le temps ben non
pas tant la tâche non non non j'ai quand
même et stein est un peu réservé les
dents vie le chpo jeu pour le but qui
parlent sont pas tous deux piges pour
gérer des classes gars comme la question
arrivait de se terrer chez placer mais
celui qui parle le plus fort dans la
guerre qui parlait de fans seconde arme
annoncé que par les plus forts la casbah
mai
annoncé ce lundi maurice 4,6 cm dont
françois pérol sur sept grands génies
médecin jours à l'entrevue le titre all
pater le 12 août angot monde qui font ce
qu'ils font pigeard cas qu'ils font
c'est packing drôle si c'est vraiment
excellent mais quand on dit qu on met la
pression de l'île maurice d'être drôle
100% du temps tout le temps j'espère que
c'est en train de changer un peu le pas
en compte que c'est des humains ils
peuvent être pas drôle mais je pense
qu'il ya de plus en plus les gens ont
conscience de tous il ya une sensibilité
à arras vraiment choqué mais ouais je me
sens pas trop le tibet alors quand le
monde sont comme les fans stone c'est la
fa qui me dérange
en ce moment c'est le monde pense que
c'est juste facile le typique et le
chipeau de recherche mais travaillent de
concert
mais c'est seulement le monde
comme je dis tantôt le but c'est de
donner l'impression au monde que c'est
la première fois qu'on le dit pis que on
est juste en train de jaser maintenant
travail derrière fac ça donne
l'impression que quand le show arrête à
studio le manche patate mais ce qu'il
faut c'est que ces petites tables on
sait les petits tout de même si ça
commence
c'est ce que titre mais énormément de
travail là dedans tu commences à adler
fait un point sur le flight games et je
t'écris genre une hymne des genres de
des gens qui dans la pandémie qui ont
besoin de s'accrocher quelque chose
s'est éteinte à tourner ça va mal ça
vraiment les gens c'est incroyable
comment qui ça a été écouté c'est une
eau m haies jeu je vous prie pas surpris
à fait le cas mais je le sentais le
titre c'est comme ça faisait un moment
mettons là j'avais cette idée là en tête
de
juste un automne qui disent avant man
comme jamais cette idée le puits quand
je les fais tu pour vous reste être
tellement libérateur de six jeux les
films et maintenant j'ai fait comme ces
atomes j'ai peut-être fait le moine take
parce que je sais comment on loue le
fils emilio self il est tellement c'est
très simple c'est 45 secondes mots qui
disent ça va mal mais je sais comment on
ne me le dit je pense qu'en ce que je
mets le doigt sur le feeling collectif
si la réponse était assez exactement ce
que je pense que je t'ai pas le seul à
me sentir de même puis en a qui se
sentent encore plus que moi les
travailleurs de la santé c'est fou j'ai
entendu dire que genre monde chante au
bureau le monde chante à l'hôpital le
monde argent partout je me fais créé pas
mal belle pas mal à tiflis mais la vaste
et à tous et jolie balle piquée à tous
les jours du nom qu'ils ont c'est notre
hymne dans la champ là tous les jours au
bureau puis la plupart déjà cédé jacques
taris amis de la santé des mains des
agents des hôpitaux ou dans des semble
quand même à d'abord rayonner l'art fait
quelque chose qui résonnait autant mais
ma maison c'est comme et c'est comme mes
parents de le voir le monde est fou
passe quelque chose qui résonne auprès
des jeunes
alors que tu veux juste faire quelque
chose qui résonne pour toi mais quand tu
touches à quelque chose c'est l'essence
même de toutes les impressions que ça
résonne auprès des autres alors que la
seule vraie affaire faut que ça résonne
auprès de tous ceux qui branle en
général c'est ce qu'il faut pour toi ça
résonne sur mac est exact mais le fait
de toucher de mettre le doigt là d'ssus
c'est comme petit panier choque pas ocz
est à qui j'ai touche à quelque chose
c'est assez spécial comme feeling études
parce que 5
en bande c que tout le monde est un peu
gentil quand la monf oreilles tâtonne et
46 ça va mal pour moi ce moment j'ai
vécu est pas cool mais tu m'as tu sais
comme tu as l'impression de vivre avec
eux autres facs hills et fauqué le
feeling est comme on est une gang dans
le format j'ai l'impression fin que si
c'est dur de l'expliquer mais quand
quand tu crées c'est le genre de lien
avec avec du monde comme pas le goût de
le perdre
premièrement puis tu te rends compte
qu'on a c'est précieux piqué c'est un
peu pour ça qu'on fait ça au final pour
le partager si c'est ça va mal maîtrisée
c'est d'amener un peu de du mollah dante
d'enfants finalement c'est tellement oui
c'est tellement bien justement je fais
pas un métier mais temps oui je souhaite
amener un peu de lumière au monde qui
sauvent des vies inutilement injustement
situe dès notre gamme d'infirmières on
la chante pieds taux qui était peut-être
au bout du rouleau gens te poses pas
changé leur vie mais l'art fait de bien
peu après six autres enfants de bien
d'autres web est exact c'est vraiment
chaud car le talent c'est que ça a pu
rejoindre demande puis leur faire un peu
de blé et
mais j'ai eu beau sauver personnes senti
un peu imaginent te sentir l'engouement
pendant cette période là mais tu sens eu
un espèce de momentum de quand même de
dire leur faut que ça te mange en zone
orange parce que là je pense qu'il est
l'intérêt des gens puis pour tout ce que
tu veux faire ensuite ça va donner un
bon coup de main ben j'ai pas
l'impression que ces gens c'est
maintenant ou jamais mais je sais que
c'est comme le timing est bon si ça fait
suspect peut-être naïf de ma part ça
fait longtemps que je t ai comme un gout
ont fait un one man show
et puis juste dix ans faut que j'attende
d'avoir assez de gens qui veulent se
déplacer pour venir me voir un show mais
que je me sens prêt pour faire un show
c'est sa fin ça fait un moment quand
même le thé fac est jugée à l'aune je
continue de travailler c'est ma passion
première fois que le savoir qu'il ya du
monde qui vont me voir je suis vraiment
excité les juges sorte que les ports
trouve depuis qu'on a à faire
parce que les jeunes 7 et la llc signé
yeux mais le juste là en fait aux en
automne quand j'ai annoncé mes premières
dates des spectacles confirmant tout
était annulé
c'était comme juste avant qu'ils
annoncent les zones rouges se trouvent
en une journée le gie avait tout vendu
milices déjà c'était des services web et
soldats non mes soldats dans une journée
c'est comme étant choisi le petit
champlain à québec laval à québec
faisait petit champlain ce genre de 230
places puis je pense je n'ai jamais fait
complètement sur le dos tu sais c'est
toujours deux sacs et housses en gravier
sur l'ambiance malade c'est ça la vie il
reste quelques billets ses souvenirs
pour le soir mais il va rester
puis là on a loué albert rousseau ce
qu'ils étaient parce que c'est 250
places mclachlan avec hérault salle puis
c'est 250 places dans une journée on te
plains le tir effectué la même ville
même nombre de billets mépris en une
journée
pas celle à qui il ya du monde mais qui
sont comme yes je veux aller le voir lui
la meilleure récompense possible de
faire comme non seulement vous
j'ai votre attention mais c'est pas
juste sol c'est comme le commun lui
jégou de préserver ma soirée de me
déplacer picon a de quoi d'alphone
ensemble ces facteurs ces précieux au
bout tu le tiens ça a fait le choix
d'être un feeling quand même intense de
dire à qui le sait une création
originale de moi les gens sont prêts à
payer est voulue par ces petites envies
de schiste les gens sont prêts à payer
pour venir me voir l'été ouais c'est
quand même deux parties je ne sais pas
et je suppose t billet coûte combien
mais c'est quand même chercher cible
mais quand même ce petit jeu dans le
monde et la plupart des gens leurs
budgets sont serrés sur le calcul et
puis dans leurs dépenses pour
divertissement mais pas la peine de
venir te voir une soirée typique quand
tu prends la peine mais ton d'aller voir
un spectacle
c'est un événement ben oui c'est fait
que j'arrête tout a [ __ ] hors de chez
vous tienne tu as ta femme dont marie
aujourd'hui plus que jamais ses jambes
et on oublie pas ton masque faut que tu
arrives un peu plus d'avancé parce que
le on range les personnes une à la fois
pour les assauts alors cerege pour que
factice et en ce moment faut vraiment
vouloir être dans une salle de spectacle
pour sa rentrée à personne qui comme ham
souhaite donner des billets ou avait
rien à faire soit bon sur un sommeil il
ya quand même beaucoup d'obstacles flou
et je le prends c'est tellement beau
compliment disposition compliment c'est
comme ça me donne le goût de de force et
je le vois toujours ça à chaque fois
j'ai envie de moi chaque afin chaude
comme ça fait une heure que je parle
même pas partie de ceux là plus que
jamais mon vrai que ça me
on dirait que la pandémie ça m'a
vraiment situerait à l'est jamais ce que
touche pendant que tu le perds le pis de
réaliser mettons la possibilité de
consommer de la culture puis de sortir
dans une salle de spectacle on dirait
que c'est quelque chose que je prenais
un peu pour acquis moi depuis que je
considérais pas vraiment comme dans
quelques je me dis qu'est ce que je fais
en fin de semaine ou qu'est-ce que je
fais j'avais pull espèce de réflexe de
me dire et je vais aller j'en paye un
billet de spectacle musée puis pis crise
c'est maintenant que je les plus je me
dis c'est la première chose que je veux
faire la prochaine fois je joue à aller
sur evenko je le souhaitais les
spectacles qui se donne pitié je vais
aller consommer de la culture parce que
c'est ce qui me manque le plus c'est en
ce moment
puis je suis sûr ça va faire seul je
passe tu le sens un peu où les oui mais
j'étais au cinoche là aussi c'est aussi
c'est vrai mais en zone rouge
puis c'est quand christie ça manque seul
c'est le feeling de jeu s'est assis puis
concert un film qui était bien
l'ambiance parfaite pour écouteurs ces
malades le soin j'adore c'est sa maman
qui est assez claire
moi j'allais quand j'étais à québec
j'allais au clapas tous les mardis parce
que c'était dès mardi
il y avait une journée où est ce que je
pouvais avoir une bière qui je me
prenais une paille
mais tous les mardis puis j'ai regardé
un film que j'avais jamais entendu
parler le très grand engagement qui sait
rester qu à le pif faisait juste aller
là je t'ai déjà lancé avec ma peine de
route boréale puis je faisais juste
écouter le film pilotes c'était devenu
ça fait partie de ma routine près quand
je suis déménagé comme arrêter de faire
ce plat aujourd'hui je réalise que
c'était tellement important je n'aurais
jamais dû arrêter parce c'est tellement
mais tellement beau cinéma ociné louis
allo ciné novo nous sommes allés voir
les montois québécois par non non non
c'est ainsi non ça coupait iata gsm a
fait c'est comme ça il ya le mot 25
points qui c'est un français il ya les
mots fleuris de la cdc des villages
privés leur floride pour les les gens
l'oratoire c'est comme si ces immenses
puis c'est comme un petit s'est
présentée un peu comme étant ce
documentaire qui nous est présenté comme
et agen le paradis de commun ces malades
du printemps et applaudir tous deux
clubs de golf tout petit tout petit tout
est pareil partout plusieurs peines pour
des clubs privés petit puis ça s'est
super aseptisé c'est juste des blancs
font quelque chose de surnaturel puis il
faut essayer c'est le portrait des gens
qui sont là des gens à la retraite qui
sont malheureux si ça faisait déjà
malheureux et qui vivent dans un endroit
où tout disposés d'abord d'être géniale
fait que ces supports toucha c'est
vraiment drôle de très drôle c'est super
beau c'est un beau portrait puis ça
t'amène à te poser plein de questions
sur la retraite la vie après la retraite
de la vie de couple
ça m'a posé plein de questions enfin que
c'est super intéressant c'est vraiment
bon c'est une commune et toi tu donnes
le soleil
grâce à des films j'aime le cinéma
beaucoup j'aimerais ça reconnaître plus
si j'aimerais savoir plus de fermeté
comme à chaque fois que je prends un
film je tripe puis comme si les mêmes
j'ai vu ma vie santana révèle mon film
préféré
l'état ne remettra jamais non j'ai quand
même le met pas pourtant j'aimerais
c'est un film qui t'ont marqué vraiment
récemment
je pense j'ai même parlé avec avec g
mais écrit dès le deuxième film de
bourgogne est vraiment bon genre à lui
son humour ressemble un peu à ce que toi
tu fais bien oui de jouer avec moi
j'aime beaucoup c'est son stand up show
- femme que j'aime beaucoup et j'aime si
thoune j'aime comment il joue avec la
scène peter mais son stand-up comme tel
c'est moi le film et je connais
collègues je vais mais je t invite à
regarder il ya des yeux 2 2 special sur
netflix et il y en a plus que seul il ya
fait plus vieille mais souvent c'est
quand même un peu moins et tafer ou
sitafa qui se retrouvent dans l'eau très
chaude après qu'il eût mieux fait mais
les deux watts puis mécaniques sont ses
deux flèches qui conseille la fil à
aiguille justement le ticket qui fait de
13 ans qui a des réseaux sociaux puis
conakry socialement ce que j'aime c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de ces justes réalistes
je n'aime pas de j'aime j'aime beaucoup
cette affaire et s'est assis le mais il
n'y a pas de pas de grosse intrigue
demeure très fiers pas de données vous
voyez c'est quand même dur comme firme
sedo écoutez je trouve tout ce dur et
d'un sens moralement ou non mais je
trouve ce seuil d'ici là le 6 et
ultramar ésente elle allait le
parrainage est trop ce que chevron
simuler de façon ultra ma récente
c'est juste c'est donc en fait je trouve
les fêtes au contraire ça m'a fait
dédramatiser cette situation là je
trouve que c'est vraiment beau portrait
de c'est vraiment petit rappel de ckoi
avoir 13 ans pilote imagine en tout cas
pour moi c'était quoi est une petite
fille de 13 ans que je n'ai pas vécu
puis la dette une petite fille de 13 ans
en 2018 cc oui ça fait mal tu as le goût
de les aider même tâté comme si c'est
juste une période de la vie difficile à
générer
enfin chose ça fait un peu des
dermatites et ça c'est drôle c'est cute
ibos il ya des moments de malaise a
vraiment marrer ça parce qu'ils sont
tellement réaliste de plein de
situations parce que chaque mois c'est
génial à maïak est le portrait de verser
je trouve que c'est super juste ni drôle
et touchant qui beaupuy pas tout changea
en vue de toucher juste comme on va te
montrer de quoi salaires puis-je vous
c'est vraiment bossé comme des petites
saynètes le dalphond n'y a pas d'eau
potable de ya un dénouement se met pas
la grosse intrigue twist schéma narratif
traditionnel des ses seules épaules
allait pas de soi et pas de gauche c'est
clair mais m
les polypes à écouter mais la question
des la question de l'accessibilité des
réseaux sociaux pour des adolescents qui
vieillissent
j'y réfléchis quand même souvent parce
que je me remets je me remets un cas on
était au secondaire début secondaire
comment qu'on n'était pas matures qu'on
n'avait pas d'intelligence émotionnelle
ou intelligence relationnelle
puis quelqu'un qu'on arrivait chez nous
définit lui on était on arriver chez
nous puis il n'y avait pas de temps et
peut-être sur msn mais sur emerson du
contact chez les gens qui tirent par le
tpiy puis le camp tarifs chez vous puis
ça finit jamais mes tontons interaction
avec ton cirque social picoler les
dynamiques entre adolescents jeunes
adolescents qui sont pas tout le temps
depuis que tu aimais toile à propos de
la popularité quelqu'un ici puis quelque
chose d'abstrait ce quelque chose de de
qualifiable oui je sais plus qui dit ça
mais si c'est la première fois que c'est
la première génération qui peut revenir
chez eux puissent sentir encore seule
fois encore d'une dans l'école puis du
secteur pas d'amis ça fait ce soir ma le
camp se retourne chez vous tout avec ta
famille tu t'es bien mais le tarif chez
vous puis tous les réseaux sociaux se
retrouvent encore pas d'amis seul face à
ce fait
oui c'est vraiment dur tpiy mais même
pour les jeunes populaires aussi ça ça
me fait par la cedh indiqué un jeune de
15 peut se mettre à voir ces deux cent
mille flowers pilotes c'est ce que ça
dit le csc
sa trente d'entre deux cent mille
personnes qui disent la personne qui
était là elle est parfaite c'est on
t'aime comme tu es change portes à 15
oui il faut que tu changes c'est oui
pour se remettre en question oui faut
cultiver tout tout seul chez vous des
fois être pas être constamment avec une
communauté sur internet puis vivre pour
les autres font tuer pour toi faut tuer
des expériences face des amis pour
suivre des connexions individuelles pas
juste toi par rapport à un groupe facile
quand tu vieillis plus tu es rendu de 21
ans mettant juste voulu rester sept
personnes là qui se fait dire par deux
cent mille personnes est extraordinaire
et ses factures
ça va pousser croche le cg mieux le
titre angèle amusant à voir comment
comment ça peut être positif se détend
de vedettes sur le web etc car j'ai
l'impression que ça peut détruire des
personnes j'ai une amie qui a un petit
goût de six ans c'était les malades du
petit gaulois y est drôle il vraiment
allumé c'est comme il y aura doublé
notre genre et c'est lire c'est
multiplier déjà bien six ans maintenant
puis il sait manier l'ipad d'une manière
incroyable
il connaît toutes les tweaks le tipi
vraiment vraiment bon type i see my man
il vraiment il manie dames en blanc est
parti puis on envoie une vidéo lo'jo
placé comme lui dans la cuisine plaisir
et à l'ipad
et puis il se met à filmer puis j'avais
6 ans puis par jose qui fait c'est à
l'eau tout le monde alors je vous faire
une vidéo de danse aujourd'hui les
hypers genre une tonne de majin dragan
plis genre y danse danse à l'ombre tout
bouge à ses parents une faune super
derrière ses fils mais jean à 6 ans il
est déjà en train d'avoir vidéos youtube
ça commence par à l'eau tout le monde
qu'il a pu ces fous pareils telus et
c'est comme il ya intégré c'est qu'au
delà de ces codes de l'internet loeb
c'est juste normal de faire une vidéo
qui repose sur youtube mais ce genre il
commence par salut tout le monde je
fasse aujourd'hui la nouvelle
j'imagine qu'ils vont
apprendre à vivre avec cette s'est lassé
par réalité a eu quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas vécu j'imagine que ça devait aussi
pour je sais pas se trouver un
équivalent à maintenir nos parents et
nos grands parrains garénaux pas du
genre à aller danser quelque chose qui
n'est autre faisait porter le c imagine
que c'est commun c'est un choc pour les
autres mais nous devons apprendre à
vivre avec ça mais c'est que je sais pas
maintenant pas moins ses seules six
relaxes et moi c'est moi si je me dis
c'est quoi maintenant comme un conte
comment encadrer tout ça parce que si si
si et pas d'encadrement c'est ça va
partir en couille dans le voit déjà que
c'est en train de partir en couille pour
mettons nos vies à nous le think puis de
comment ça peut être dangereux qui
polarise ans puis participer à la
séparation dans société plus pudiquement
ckoi mettant comme un con là encore
c'est recettes c'est comment qu'on va de
l'avant avec tout ça si tu pars des
cours d'éthique stupar mettons comme
comme alexandre champagne qui a lancé sa
fondation le centre l'intelligence
émotionnelle en ligne fait que c'est
comme pour apprendre justement que lille
ait défini sport piquette toutes ces
choses le sont mais c'est quoi me tonti
c'est ça je pense a fait paraître un peu
seul et un peu l'inconnu dans le fond
ben oui puis j'ai connu il y en a
toujours eu et exact il le pour nous
c'est sûr désolé jeune fille grande qui
naissent fille qui peuvent être est en
contact des jeux avec une mine au logis
fac et wej sûr que ce serait une bonne
manière c'est juste 2 c'est pas de leur
acheter c'est de chercher d accéder je
sais pas le d'apprendre aux jeunes j'ai
pas je pense que c'est un bon truc quand
même un hypothétique coup je sais pas à
l'école taurine séchage l'interaction
entre êtres humains je trouve ça te
ferait quelque chose qui dunke déjà
apprises à l'école mais c'est pour le
côté mais les cours de morale c'est que
c'est de faire ce jour là par la
religion l'écoulement discuter avec
d'autres êtres humains sans avoir l'air
au coin de la place
info que jésus t'aime avoir pour être
capable de coudre ses boxeurs une
discussion lo'jo signé par an surtout
les gens parler mordant qui filme à
s'arrêter à moi j'avais été là dessus
puis le pilote et on explique un peu le
concept à mes parents qui a aucune
difficulté
moi je trouve que je trouve ça n'a pas
de sens le que ce soit en dessous en
attendant le temps de rencontrer des
gens pour de vrai et puis comme les
métiers en scoot clar moi je bouge
connaît le ritalin t elle qui sont
rencontrés là dessus puis ils sont
heureux ici et ça permet de nanas en
piste une nouvelle façon pour les gens
et ils vont peut-être t se sauve un peu
moins sûr surtout en ce moment à plis
bah oui dans le fond dans le fond quoi
vraiment et c'est vraiment de la petite
de juste là l'action de ce bois épais à
gauche à droite qui vraiment comme docx
et des humains sont des produits de la
marchandise qui était comme si oui oui
non oui non mais en bout de ligne je
veux dire ça sacré de vraie interaction
humaine
et puis des fois oui et puis je pense
qu'il faut s'y faire confiance au
discernement des gens là je pensais y a
personne qui contender c'est la vie
c'est ça la vie c'est je pense pas parce
qu'effectivement le message que
l'application envoie effectivement ce
pas le meilleur mais chez cappelle
alternative le type o fauqué c'est au
final je pense qu'il ya des gens que tu
lis tindouf sont très conscients qui
comme sport représentatif d'une vraie
relation interpersonnelle mais surtout
d'un jeu n'est pas parce qu'on manipule
dans un moment de la vie où est ce qu'on
a pu l'interaction entre les gens les
cinq suspects c'est une denrée rare de
pouvoir s'asseoir autour d'une table et
discuter non mais c'est un exercice je
pense que les gens qui coûte des films
de guerre aussi son bonnet serment
je comprenais sa malegoude al-agha alors
ça c'est les gens qui se disent tu aimes
deux savent que les humains sont pas des
mêmes la marchandise c'est un peu ça
aussi le temps j'ose croire à un les
pauvres sous pour les jeunes je pensais
plus important de passer le message
s'est fait que pour ce jeu pas j'ai
l'impression que ça passe par
l'éducation de bois juste faire semblant
que les réseaux sociaux ça n'existe pas
internet ça existe pas je pense que
c'est important de bien éduquer parce
que sinon c'est un peu la jungle et ils
vont apprendre par eux-mêmes pis c'est
un peu une guerre de popularité beaucoup
le titre chez les jeunes un ace
casquette us 1 que ça l'est aussi un peu
dans un milieu comme celui d'humour une
grande popularité
ouais ça c'est parce que j'ai le feeling
qui tient maintenant tu calcules un
peut-être surtout en ce moment dans
l'époque covin le tuc un peu ta
popularité il ya tant de succès par les
buts
j'imagine que oui si j'essaye vraiment
en tout cas personnellement de pau y
accorder d'importance pour focus la
vraie réponse le jeu c'est vraiment de
patrice capable je dirais 90 % oui c'est
une couple de fois route sur toi fin
c'est en fait c'est vraiment plus facile
quand ed des vidéos virales ça marche
facile de faire un point important
ça n'a jamais fait et comme celui ci
s'appuie musique c'est quand même
entendre quelqu'un qui fait 1.5 million
par année dire que l'argent sale aucune
importance et comme je comprends que
larcher en plus d'importance pour toi
mais comme moi avec trois enfants qui
poker d'arriver au bout de temps je
prendrai ce sens mieux le plus exact
factice pour ceux en ce moment chez soi
c'est fastoche le t de pommes en bourse
avec sur mer est cueilli une jambe il ya
un rythme jan peumans ce sur tout ça
entre que mon choix go à ce moment c'est
une niche mais tu as aidé à faire même
si c'est pas gentil tu as est fort
lauwers et je mets tu as aidé à faire
pour nourrir la pâte en cg c'est de
sortir d'affaires gaza
tante quand j'ai une motivation au
piquage commence aussi à ça ça va être
bon jeu pas juste sortir quelque chose
pour sortir quelque chose puisse gérer
leur fin de semaine jérémy faut admettre
- pays c'est de trouver quelque chose
qui va plaire au nom si le mangeant de
combat ce moment fac c'est sûr que je
trouve difficile c'est de voir plein
d'humour est qui met plein d'affaires
puis qui sont actifs financiers corinne
fau drait du choix actif mais aussi puis
c'est facile dans ma position de dunes
on regarde payable jemmapes attentes
puis chez qui un charme la femme et
imagine décidé à garder cette même
philosophie le mais quand quand juste
mettons dignité ou diplôme il favorise
qui dit quand j'en sors un ch'ti j'ai
juste 150 view stacy que mon problème
alors que ce point mais c'est dur de ne
pas accorder une importance assez ouais
ouais puis se met ça c'est mes temps au
delà sait pas ce qu'est ce que tu dis ça
résonne tellement au sens où si le
challenge je pense de pipi servient
disent pas ce que tu disais décide de
communiquer à d'autres gens alors qu'est
ce que tu veux c'est vraiment
communiquer à tous je pense que l'idée
qu'on s'est fait martelé de l'algorithme
puis du succès de la constante pression
de produire c'est j'ai l'impression que
c'est vraiment contre productif puis que
ça va dans le fond à l'encontre la
qualité c'est maintenant l'algorithme va
pousser les gens qui produisent plus en
moins grande qualité mettons le au
dessus ou qui vont tous mais tombe sur
instagram vous parler de quelque chose
que je connais le 2 mai temps du monde
qui font le qui pose des scènes fit une
seule fille par jour tous les jours puis
la guérite beaucoup c'est surtout voir
plus de like parce que tu penses à tous
les jours mais tabarre max toujours une
stèle ville de menton miroir tout le
temps avec un nouveau vote fit cette
journée là mais toujours bien même un
contenu un peu vide qui typique parce
que puis je monte là ils font bien parce
qu'ils jouent avec les codes qui leur
sont donnés mais de produire tout le
temps quelque chose puisqu'elle est venu
du froid mais pourquoi pourquoi la
grille tu pousses le contenu comme ce
qui est juste mais juste
la fréquence parce que parce que c'est
une compagnie si c'est ça je sais qu'il
fait chier c'est que c'est c'est notre
plateforme pour lancer pour la musique
pour l'euro c'est les réseaux sociaux
fait puis lyon l'intervenant ne s'est
pas juste nous face au public c'est nous
face à une compagnie qui relayent au
public fax et ses terres je veux pas
jouer cette gameblog tv vidéo sur ton
site web tu les partages nulle part
ailleurs et attend cet om triple w http
de points bas résume à risque qui ont
acquis acquis une notoriété au fil des
ans qui font sauter chicon qui ont
tellement un gros following t aux états
unis qui ont tellement gros following
qui sont pas sur les plates formes son
petit tour en rien de leur stock sur
spotify sur itunes je peux aller checker
leur show sur leur site web ce n'est
plus possible parce que y ont acquis
leur notoriété jadis mais le support de
0,10 par un site web se mettront
cholette steve ans a vu les héros c'est
ce qui te va parler à pas en parler de
bouche à oreille est à ta famille glazer
est maman de suivre sûrement sans parler
de quelque chose qui parle qui va parler
au monde mais notre pote followers
faculté sparrow des chaises mais pour ça
faut que ce soit ne peut pas appeler fac
le tuteur troupes il est identifié par
studio afin que moi je suis juste bon
1200 for law lui est bon ça veut dire
qu'il est dix fois meilleur que moi mais
ce pas de même ça marche mais le tout
sous ça vient jouer sur ta confiance
mais une compagnie entre les deux qui
gère ce qui qui tout un intervenant
l'algorithme c'est comme c'est ce qui ce
qui change tout
effectivement il faut se rappeler le mot
algorithmes il y en a un c'est injuste
je passais gens
sitôt jeu c'est un nombre de likes et
puis c'est quoi la main au début mais là
il poussera pas autant il faut genre les
premières personnes l'agpi cher c'est
tellement absurde de la manière que
s'est construit c'est fait pour que tu
te battre contre une compagnie s'est
fixé comme faut se rappeler de tout il
faut se rappeler quand elles font pas
fait pour ça je saute à sa propre
perception du corps l'école du c#
je pense que c'est une coupe dan ellis
maurice qui faisait des vidéos des
capsules sur facebook ça se répandent
est incroyable puis la manne est en fait
qu'ils n'ont pas payé leurs enfants avec
ce taux qui mène au frotte pays braque
allemand le voyez autant puis le salsa
le crash est le cefac dès qu'il voit
quelqu'un peut un peu trop profiter de
la plateforme ces contrats qui ne fait
pas d'argent c'est vraiment important si
ce test du support bonbons ce ne sera
plus jamais vu comme ça de se rappeler
qu'il ya un intervenant dans dans tout
ce qu'on fait rire les réseaux sociaux
et à quand une compagnie privée au final
qui décide de la valeur des apports
c'est dur de ne pas accorder
d'importance à cette ces jeux c'est le
cas en ce moment moi je suis gros dur
parce que j'ai fait des vidéos qui était
pire alpha clair en ce moment je te vois
qui trouve emma patente métis c'était ça
va je faisais des sketches que j'espère
que ça va chercher des views mais en
bout de ligne si c'est adobe et bah oui
puis non maintenant c'est que ce qui est
chiant c'est que ça ça mousse ou du
moins si tout le monde quelque chose
moi ce qui me fout la brigade des fois
ci c'est du monde qui pose ses réseaux
sociaux folle folle folle et puis faute
auprès photo mais je me dit c'est quoi
la motivation parce que mettons un
musicien un humoriste ou ticket
quelqu'un qui a gagné de faire connaître
je comprends pourquoi qui fait seuil a
pas le choix de jouer à ce jeu là parce
que en bout de ligne il veut vend des
billets éventuellement de corrèze qu'ils
meurent son spectacle ce également les
coûts de s'amuser fac il fuit les
réseaux sociaux de contenu mettez
quelqu'un qui quitte il a même arrêté
demandant aux politiques qui ont des
jobs de jeu
le thé infirmières ainsi ce prof qui
sont ultra kitsch réseaux sociaux je ne
juge pas ça mais il faut que je me
demande pourquoi
mais quoi être aussi active et est aussi
à la recherche de like caxito pas besoin
de ça pour vivre il ya plusieurs je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs motivations
derrière puis c'est pour ce qui est dit
fabien de police jugée mal en plus
j'essaie de poche jugé ce parce que
c'est pas mon objectif personnel
franchement pas jaloux de ne pas fâcher
le dessus je pense qu'il y ait beaucoup
de ça devient addictif aussi c'est quand
tu vois j'ai grossi depuis que les
chambres x5 en plus vite et je pense que
ça a toujours existé sur la personne qui
a besoin d'attention ces puits serment
et où maurice parler sur scène une
partie du terrain si j'ai le choix de
vouloir qui est du monde qui m'écoutent
7 y compris en fait je veux profond au
final qui gagnent partie de moi qui veut
avoir des gens qui m'écoutent en train
de faire des jobs veut faire le monde
oui je veux le faire pour eux je le
ferais pas ça pour ça pour moi
évidemment mais il ya une partie de la
motivation qu'il faut qu'il y ait du
monde pour m'écouter fait une partie de
toi aussi de genre de du besoin de
l'attention des gens ça a toujours
existé ceux du monde qui veulent être
enfin être le chef d'un gang d'une
grosse gagne d'abord une grosse
communauté tu as toujours ça a toujours
existé plus avec les réseaux sociaux
mais c'est comme ça jamais été aussi
accessible
d'abord aux gains je pense que si jean
de dieu des gens qui sont programmés
comme ceux qui ont grandi comme ceux
d'avoir besoin de faire partie d'une
gamme de sentir que tu est importante
dans ta gang fait glisser comme quelque
chose qui arrête jamais d'être nourris
de ces facs il est un peu ça j'imagine
la motivation de vouloir être populaire
mais ça a toujours existé vous des gens
qui veulent juste être célèbre puis j'ai
effectivement comme je juge pour sa pige
pas jaloux de ces gens là
oui je sais qu'il parce que je dis ça
parce que si j'ai des collègues
humoristes c'est qu'ils regardent se
faire qu'à ma soeur ils ont tant de
followers pis ils font rien et
intéressante ils font juste parler d'eux
puisque effectivement team est faux pas
de jaloux de 7 6% son objectif aussi
c'est quoi toi ce que tu veux c'est pour
ça c'est de créer quelque chose puis
tant mieux si le monde en battant chacun
pourquoi c'est dur à dire parce que j'ai
pas cette motivation mais je pense que
c'est une affaire ça flatte l'ego ça
fait du bien de sentir que tu as gagné
grossi fac j'ai l'impression que c'est
leur bus pour de créer des d'arriver
avec une nouvelle idée ou rien c'est
juste de faire grossir sa communauté
mais je pense que ce que tu viens de
sérieux c'est super important de cibler
qu'est ce que toi tu veux puis une fois
que tu es carrère de sublimes de le
mettre en mode de le verbaliser plus
d'être capable de vraiment mettre le
doigt dessus tout le tout devient plus
clair j'ai l'impression moi je sais que
ça mais tu avais en est tombé dans un
espèce de patronne de me dira qu'il faut
chaud actifs oxo active ses réseaux
sociaux parce que parce qu'il faut que
les affaires les petits puits puis après
sujet je me suis reculé puis je me suis
dit ok c'est quoi vraiment pourquoi est
ce que je veux être active ses réseaux
sociaux parce que je peux seulement ma
finalité je veux pas avoir d abonnés je
prends un gros engagement suppose que je
cherche fait qu'est ce que cherche
vraiment puisque chercher c'était de
faire le pas de calais face kim ce qui
m'intéressait pour vrai puis je me suis
dit ok mais enfin si le monde sont pas
intéressés quand je parle du podcast les
plateformes de réseaux sociaux par les
serments du monde que je veux qu'ils me
suivent un diminutif à qui ça m'amène de
différent de juste parler de tout à fait
que fait de cibler peut-être exactement
ce que ce que tu recherches
ben oui tu puisses pas s'appliquer
j'imagine que ça s'applique pendant
juste pour les gens qui critiquent comme
ce sera google et si je pense pas que
l'utilisateur moyen d'instagram se pose
ces questions le mais c'est un homme son
combat aussi que je viens tous les jours
de fêtes chasser d'affaires baisser ce
qui est dur c'est qu'en ce moment
plus que jamais c'est comme notre seule
manière bien évidemment il ya la télé au
6 mai
je peux pas me concentrer sur ce que
j'aime faire ça dit de la scène facebook
j'aime poster des vidéos sur internet le
james e mais effectivement que s'il ya
beaucoup de à des fins d'autopromo lada
fac c'est plate de le voir demain ça
c'est ma plate forme d'auto promotion
c'est une autre affaire c'est aussi les
créateurs c'est tellement puissant les
réseaux sociaux que c'est comme quand tu
es d'un jeune humoriste c'est la
première fois que tu dises il faut que
j'aille chercher des chercheurs en
baisse alors que c'est peut-être même
pas ses banques sur ce que tu fais
encore sur cinq
je suis même pas encore assez étoffé
pour c'est tout besoin seulement ce
qu'ils voient c'est de la merde tels que
c'est pas beau ça va c'est de la merde
je dis pas besoin de dix mille personnes
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup de monde
dix mille personnes soit besoin de dix
mille personnes qui tu m'as ce moment
c'est ça vaut la peine
alors on apprend beaucoup à
s'autopromouvoir avant même d'avoir
quelque chose à promouvoir ces sept ans
quand même avec les réseaux sociaux si
ça fait partie du quotidien le devoir de
chercher plus de c'est comme mettre une
charrue en avant des buts a mis en avant
des bâtiments ça devrait te mens une
[Rires]
expertise
la charrue lobo est ce que avant de
réaliser ce que tu penses que qu'en
mettant les parce que là on voit plus
que jamais le du contenu d'humoristes
sur les socios que ce soit sous forme de
vidéo que ce sous forme de podcast se
forme il y en a il y en a pu savoir quoi
en faire
est-ce que je pense que quand les salles
de spectacles vont réouvrir ce ça va se
calmer un peu où c'est une tendance
continue je sais pas c'est une bonne
question mais c'est sur le 6 est là pour
rester le séisme les humoristes présents
sur les réseaux sociaux de ceux ci à pau
mais un moyen justement de 10 par
découvrir fois que je passe cette année
que je fasse que je t'avais c'est juste
qu'il y ait été depuis le début la
pandémie est en est que c'est maintenant
quand tu fais quatre shows parce par son
art semaine pas le temps de commencer à
bouquet des podcasts puis à fin mai les
solutions qu'ils auront moins de
podcasts j'imagine c'est j'imagine que
oui mais si l'enjeu c'est sûr je sais je
sais pas moi personnellement c'est sur
des jantes et je force un peu plus se
chauffer un système déjà moins à face
aux réseaux sociaux pas que oui
j'imagine ça va ça va peut-être se
calmer mais je pense que tu si ça reste
que c'est la bonne et marseille font
aussi pour les consommateurs tu sais
quand même savoir un petit peu de un
petit peu de cet art là que j'aime dans
le quotidien s'en est obligé de me
déplacer cet objet de oui c'est ça pis
moi et moi même ma passion
c'est la scène mais je dis encore une
fois tu disposes 100% qui choque pas que
ça évidemment je cavale de faire dans la
vidéo des petites chansons comme on le
disait c'est quelque chose que je
continue de faire soi même parce que
j'aime ce le faire même s'il y en a que
leur passion c'est 100% la scène y en a
qui aiment tête sur mon genre d'hybride
factice pour ce que je pense que ça va
se mélanger aussi a été mauvais ce
serait pas juste avoir un one man show
par an tandis que tu racontes douce et
que tu viennes métier je pense que c'est
on a parlé la forme va s'éclater puis
aussi ça on va donner un peu les gens
débrayé de l'été je pense que pour
retrouver beaucoup de trucs sur internet
puis ça peut être une finalité il y en a
déjà l'été chez carac san bruno surtout
qualifie d' du mot respect si c'est vrai
j'ai dit que j'aurais fait des sketches
pour pas ce qu'a fait pour jean claude
mathis monaco c'est le oui je pense est
là pour rester c'est là aussi pour elle
ça va varier je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui vont varier la rue lalau
coffre à outils pis je pense que on
n'aura plus la même définition de ses
couettes un humoriste et je pensais pas
obligé d'être un gobelin qui parlait de
sa blonde comme ce qui est déjà
d'essuyer savais que je l'abordé sans
mentionner la telli comme moyen encore
très efficace de se reconnaître puis
rendu le comique relève de tracadie
ouais ouais c'est cool ça c'est venu
c'est du camas affable il malade mardi
il faut faire d'autres tentations la
chute arrive j'ai fait des jo ouais ça a
marché
oui mais la demande et on est 3 e dans
le fond à mélissa beaudin il faut puis
on fait des petits jo pts et j'aime bien
ça moi ce que j'aime c'est joe des
actions donnent l'opportunité de faire
des jo qui est dans un cadre aussi
grandiose que star académie ce contexte
qui est tu m'étonnes marchois
l'apparition 6 un contexte qui gros
stress en autriche il dérive le tri joe
pilote est que ben et they live juste
une fois la lumière les deux autres
depuis c'est déjà des trucs des capsules
avec la famille adams et selon la
famille mais le live en général je sais
pas j'ai chaussé grise sous sol font en
fait j'aime ce jeu
j'aime ça le gêne j'ai marqué les gens
de denges la cgem je ne l'aïe justement
je ne suis pas les sketchs d'anticancer
prixtel petit mais il ya quelque chose
de l'fun le chou avec les gens c'est lol
le tout épicé
ça va être ça va être pris dans le
temple ça va rester le même puis à
personne ne peut le toucher c'est ce qui
nous rend un peu plus sud qui vivent le
métier lorsque pour la grèce afin de
présenter le topo mais non je me fasse
la famille et moi très cool puis on
parlera sociaux depuis tantôt les gens
tuent et vous qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'est ce que tu invites les enfants
tchèques étaient choqués qu'ils n'ont
mêmes et réseaux sociaux et un peu
partout sous mon nom c'est nasa
[Rires]
puis arrive redémarrer les partout sur
les réseaux sociaux le vous allez me
trouver assez facilement n'ai pas
beaucoup de pièces ne suis pas mal des
six advenant que la situation presque
mal et où qui est des zones rouges qui
devient rendre ce que tu as des shows de
planifier que les gens peuvent acheter
les billets encore aussi tout son père
ivre a démarré points comme le en ce
moment gatineau en ce moment en zone
orange les autres maisons de rougemont
et ici ça va peut-être être appelé à
changer très large
oui c'est ça sherbrooke là dedans il y
aura parmi les monuments brassard québec
fait assez de mémoire le chèque-cadeau
et marcal et choqué c'est la fois que
j'aime le plus c'est caché du monde qui
viennent se déplacer pour qu'on fasse de
joker merci merci
les boîtiers